get out turns these kind of horror
tropes on its head by having a black
protagonist did already that allow you
to be able to go anywhere and be very
free from any horror tropes it already
puts a different skin on the film than
we've seen I remember there was a
distinct point in the creation of this
movie where I said this can be a movie
with a black protagonist that's just a
horror movie or I can go a trace and you
know I don't want it to become a crutch
of mine that I'm just only doing sort of
things about race but I felt like this
was something this was a movie that
deserved to be made and it was a missing
piece of the genre this is a very weird
combination this is certainly a horror
movie
it's an incredible thriller it's a
flat-out comedy in amazing moments and
it's a really important social
commentary yeah you're hitting them with
a punch line you know or with a hacksaw
yeah and you know I don't think it's a
coincidence that when a comedian does
well they say they killed it do you
think that this story really has
international resonance and appeal first
of all I can just be entertaining as a
good horror movie with yeah it is scary
but then also anyone who's ever felt
like another in a gathering of any kind
and that can mean whatever it means can
relate to it so why do you think horror
and sci-fi ah places where you can talk
about wider social issues I think it
makes a comment more yeah kind of like I
think you should say something directly
some people don't hear it and so yeah
you need to you need to be able to
arrive to it to use by yourself and
piece it together this movie was made in
the the pattern of Rosemary's Baby and
The Stepford Wives movies about the the
about gender about men making choices
from women without their consent and
they're very entertaining and they have
these dark twisted satires and reveals
that that that's how I knew this movie
was possible I love the fact that you're
a huge film net
because I am as well don't call myself a
film a film stud
yes so how long is this being known on
this thing apparently the whole bunch of
brothers they miss it to this summer
[Music]